[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hello, and
welcome to episode number
44 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey, Francesc.
How are you doing today?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very
happy to have you back.
How was Strange Loop?
MARK MANDEL: Strange
Loop was fantastic.
That is definitely one of
my favorite conferences
of the year.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm very
jealous of the t-shirt
you're wearing right now.
I think we should tweet
a picture of that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Because
that's pretty amazing.
MARK MANDEL: They have a great
Stranger Things-themed Strange
Loop t-shirt.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: It's
very well done.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It is very cool.
I kind of want one now.
But anyway, so today
we're going to be talking
with two of our coworkers, Dan
Ciruli and Sep Ebrahimzadeh,
both working in Google
Cloud Endpoints.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we have a
really interesting conversation
about what Endpoints is, what it
does, why you'd want to use it,
how you can use it, not
just within Google Cloud
but also across Cloud.
It's really, really cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it is very interesting.
Especially, if you are
serving any kind of API.
I think that it is worth for
you listening to this interview,
you're going to learn
some stuff and maybe
make your life easier.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
I think I actually
want to integrate it into
some demos that I have now.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm going
to integrate with some demos
that I have.
I'm already working on it.
And it is actually
incredibly nice, especially
not having to deal
with [INAUDIBLE].
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Because
it is not my thing.
Then after that, we'll have
the question of the week.
And today we do not have
the Cool Things of the Week.
We have the Questions
of the Week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We're going to
have two questions of the week.
One is related to a topic
that we covered before.
And of course, some of
the week, how to access
metadata from a pension.
The second one is
more about, OK,
so I have a bunch of different
front ends to my back end.
How do I manage this?
Things to make it reusable
and as simple as possible.
But before that,
we're going to have
the Cool Thing of
the Week, which
is about a German philosopher.
MARK MANDEL: Kafka.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I don't know
if he's German now, actually.
MARK MANDEL: I have no idea.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Actually, I think so.
[LAUGH]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Let me check
because I'm almost sure.
Philosopher.
MARK MANDEL: Francesc
is looking on the air.
So if you're not familiar
with Apache Kafka
while Francesc is
looking things up,
it's a messaging
system that is very
popular for a lot of people.
Open source.
We have Pub/Sub as a mini
messaging system here
on Google Cloud Platform.
But a lot of people do use Kafka
in and outside of Google Cloud
platform.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
he wrote in German,
but he was actually
from the Czech Republic,
from the
Austro-Hungarian Empire.
MARK MANDEL: Important
information for everyone.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very,
very important information.
I like important information.
Basically, what
we are announcing,
which I think is really
cool, is the fact
that if you are a
Kafka user, you're
going to be able to integrate
very well with a bunch
of our technologies.
So one of the ones that
I'm the most excited about
is the fact that you can
integrate with Cloud Pub/Sub.
Both ways.
So you can send from
Pub/Sub to Kafka and back.
But then since you have that,
there's a bunch of other things
that also work.
One of them is, you can use
it as a source for BigQuery.
So you can stream into
BigQuery using Pub/Sub.
You can also do
it now with Kafka.
And finally, there's
also the possibility
of doing the same thing
streaming to Apache Beam
or Dataflow.
Actually, Dataflow
and Apache Beam
are pretty much the same thing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
no, I really like this
because if you want to put
Pub/Sub in your Workflow,
you can.
So you can go Kafka
to Pub/Sub and then
Pub/Sub to a number
of different things
like BigQuery or Dataflow.
But if you don't want to
have another messaging
system within your system,
maybe for complexity's sake,
wanting to make
your life easier.
You can go straight
from Kafka to Dataflow,
or straight from Kafka to
BigQuery, which I think
that's really, really cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it is very interesting,
especially for those that
are already using Kafka
and were considering
using things
like BigQuery for
big data analysis
and understanding
better their business.
I think it's a
great opportunity.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely,
I really, really like it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
and we'll have links
to both the blog post and
also all the code, which
is on GitHub.
So you can go check it out.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Cool.
Well why don't we go talk to
Dan and Sep about Endpoints.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds good.
Let's do that.
So I'm very excited to
welcome Dan Ciruli and Sep
Ebrahimzadeh, Product
Manager and Software Engineer
to the Google Club
Platform Podcast.
Hello.
How are you doing?
DAN CIRULI: Hello.
Doing great.
SEP EBRAHIMZADEH:
I'm doing very well.
Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hello.
So we're here today
to talk a little bit
about Cloud Endpoints.
But before that, I would like
to know a little bit more
about who you are.
So could you tell the
audience who are you
and what do you do at Google?
So we can start with you, Dan.
DAN CIRULI: My
name is Dan Ciruli.
I'm a Product Manager on Google
Cloud Endpoints and Google's
API infrastructure.
I've been here for
about three years,
and my team not only
builds Endpoints
but builds all the
infrastructure that
serves all of Google's APIs.
Virtually all of Google's APIs.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
What about you, Sep?
SEP EBRAHIMZADEH: Great,
so I'm Sep Ebrahimzadeh
and I'm a Tech Lead
Software Engineer.
I've been at Google for
about 3 and 1/2 years,
and I work on Endpoints
and the API infrastructure.
I previously worked on
Computer Engine and other Cloud
products.
I'm very excited to be here
chatting with you guys.
MARK MANDEL: OK, cool.
So Cloud Endpoints recently got
re-released, or released again,
or enhanced.
It's different.
It's new.
Tell us what Cloud
Endpoints is now.
What does it do?
DAN CIRULI: Endpoints is--
Cloud Endpoints is Google's API
management product.
And you're right.
There's a previous incarnation.
I'm sure we'll get
into it a little bit.
It used to be a
feature of App Engine.
And it's now a
product on its own.
And Endpoints lets
you manage your APIs.
And by manage, I mean you want
to get information from them,
know who's using them, how
much they're using them.
You want to be able to control,
authorize, things like that.
Google Cloud Endpoints
is what lets customers
do that on Google Cloud.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So basically, it's
going to allow me to
provide REST APIs?
DAN CIRULI: Well, there's
a lot of ways for you
to provide REST APIs.
Right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah
DAN CIRULI: I don't know what
your favorite language is.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Python.
[LAUGHTER]
DAN CIRULI: Let's
say it was Python.
You might want to use Flask
or Django to make a REST API.
You might like a language where
people don't use frameworks
so much to make APIs.
And that's OK.
What we want to
do with Endpoints
is control who has
access to that API
and give you really good
monitoring information about
who's using that API and how.
Is it healthy?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK,
so it is not much as
about serving an API
as much as giving
like a layer of protection
and authentication,
and stuff like that.
On top of the REST API.
DAN CIRULI: Right,
and we do have
a couple of API frameworks.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
DAN CIRULI: One in
Java, one in Python.
Those started its
App Engine features.
They've now been open
sourced and can run anywhere.
Those actually are
lightweight frameworks
that can help you serve an API.
But most people already
have a favorite framework
that they're using.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
DAN CIRULI: We already
have a language of choice.
We know that we want
to be able to work
with anybody, regardless
of language and framework.
MARK MANDEL: So if
I got this right.
So if I'm building
a REST Endpoint
and I want common features,
say like [? logging ?]
or authentication, or
some other things along
those sort of lines.
That's the sort of stuff
that I'm looking at.
So what then are the-- if you
had to give four or five bullet
points for that tooling that
I wanted with Endpoints,
is it [? logging? ?] You
mentioned authorization.
What are those points?
DAN CIRULI: So we did
a bunch of surveys
before we got going
with this to find out
what our customers needed.
And people use APIs in a
big variety of situations.
Sometimes it's to power
their mobile apps.
Sometimes it's between
micro-services.
Sometimes it's for their
partners to use it.
But there is a certain
core set of features
that everybody seemed to need.
First of all is authentication.
Right.
Whether it's a service
that's making a call
or it's a user that's
holding your mobile app
or logged into your
website, you need
to know on behalf of whom
that API call is being made.
Second is logging
and monitoring.
Ops are very important.
Status is very important.
And you want to be able to
know is the API working?
Is it working well and
what are latencies?
Scalability always
comes in really huge.
Even customers who aren't
running at large scale,
it actually comes in number
one on their long list
of requirements.
They want to know
that, if it takes off,
if I become the next Pokemon Go,
if I even need 1,000 requests
a second, can this do it?
And then the last
thing is, they want
to know who's making the call?
Which developer is
making the call?
Every API call actually
represents two entities, right?
There's the developer
who wrote that code.
You want to know that.
And you want to
know the user who's
holding that mobile device.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Interesting.
So could you talk a little
bit more about that.
So you talked about
authentication
and who is doing it.
How do you explain that?
What are the ways I can do that?
Right.
So some of the ways that
Google's own APIs provide
authentication to
their consumers
are with Google's API
keys and OAuth tokens
and service-to-service auth.
And all of those
ways are actually
available for Endpoints
service producers as well.
So if you have your
own API and want
to put your own mobile
app in front of it,
you can use the same
authentication mechanisms
that you would use if
that mobile app was
calling one of Google's APIs.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Well, you
mentioned previously, Dan,
that there was a previous
version of Endpoints that
works with App Engine.
So are there any
limitations technologically
in terms of how I can
do my rest endpoints,
or is that just
like a free-for-all?
Can I put it anywhere?
DAN CIRULI: It's a free-for-all.
You can put it anywhere.
As you may or may not
know, we are members
and we're founding members
of the Open API Initiative.
And the Open API
Initiative is a bunch
of people, organizations
from around
the internet--
SmartBear, who owns
the Swagger Project, Apogee,
Microsoft, IBM, Capital One.
A bunch of different providers
came together and said,
we should all agree
on a specification
format for an API.
And there's a bunch
of reasons for that,
and maybe I'll get
into some of those.
But this is the spec, that used
to be called the Swagger spec,
is now called the
Open API spec is how
you tell us about your APIs.
So I don't care
how you develop it.
I don't care what
language you use.
framework you use.
As long as you can give
endpoints, an Open API
specification for that
API, then Endpoints
can manage the API for you.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
I'm going to redirect
to Sep, because you're
being really quiet over there.
But there are frameworks
that you said have come out.
There's a Java framework
and a Python framework.
What does that give me, above
and beyond the tooling, that's
sort of like the infrastructure
tooling that I have available?
SEPEHR EBRAHIMZADEH: Yeah.
I want to turn your question
around a little bit.
I think what you're
trying to ask
is, why should I use Endpoints?
These solutions and the
problems that we talked about
are not new, and there
are many other products
in this space that provide
logging and monitoring
and authentication.
Why should I do Endpoints?
And we talked about
the customer who
suddenly has a lot of
success with their app
and has a lot of users.
Well, it turns out that need
for logging and monitoring
and authentication
happens very quickly.
As soon as you get a couple
hundred, a few thousand users,
it turns out that
your users will
care a lot about whether
your app is up and running
or not or whether your APIs
are up and running or not.
And at that point,
it's a little too late
to go spend a couple of weeks
learning about a logging
service and a monitoring
service and then
a separate
authentication framework.
What Endpoints does is it
packages all of those API
management features
into one solution,
and it tries to reduce
the amount of work
that the developer
has to do in order
to integrate with each
one of these features one
by one, by aggregating
all of them
and say, you, focus on
your core competency,
pick any framework you like,
pick any language you like,
and build your back end APIs.
What we will do is
we will provide you
all of these
features, and all you
have to do in order to
take advantage of them
is provide an Open API
specification for your API,
right?
So what is it that you get from
the frameworks specifically?
The frameworks allow you
to annotate your code
and generate that API
specification from it.
And then you can choose to use
the API management features
or just use that Open
API specification
to generate clients in
different languages that
can call your API or take
advantage of other features,
like [INAUDIBLE] UIs that
let you explore your API.
Does that answer your question?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I think so.
It sounds like basically the
frameworks make it easier
to come up with that
Swagger or Open API specs
rather than trying to write
it by hand, for example.
Would that be correct?
SEPEHR EBRAHIMZADEH: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So the way you
explained it, I think
it's very interesting,
because it really
sounds like there's basically
a bundle of features that
are opinionated, and it
makes your life easier
as a developer.
It really sounds like
App Engine to me.
And App Engine also comes
with some constraints, right?
What are the constraints,
other than the fact
that you need to use an
Open API or a Swagger spec
for Endpoints?
Is there anything else
that we should know?
SEPEHR EBRAHIMZADEH: I will
redirect that to Dan, I think.
DAN CIRULI: Yeah,
no, I don't think so.
In some ways our
frameworks are opinionated.
But I would say that the
use of the Open API spec
is, in a sense, to
avoid "opinionation,"
if that's the word.
[LAUGHTER]
We want you to be able
to choose your back end.
And by, the way,
Cloud Endpoints-- I'm
surprised we got this far in the
podcast before I mentioned it,
bad product manager--
runs on App Engine.
But you can also use
it from Compute Engine.
You can use it from
a Container Engine.
You can use it from wherever.
The proxy that performs
the API management features
is designed to be containerized
and deployed anywhere.
So one of the big requests
we had from existing people
who were using
our frameworks was
they wanted to
move to App Engine
flexible environments
they wanted
to move to Container Engine.
Now they can do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very nice.
So could it work also on App
Engine with other frameworks
other than Java and Python?
DAN CIRULI: That's a
fantastic question,
and the answer is not yet,
but we're working on that.
We need some work from
the App Engine team.
We need some work from our
networking team as well.
But we would love
you to be able to,
yeah, pick your own
favorite framework
and run that on App Engine.
That's going to take
a coordinated effort,
but we'd love for
that to happen.
MARK MANDEL: Is that
a restriction that's
specific to App Engine
Standard or App Engine Standard
and Flexible?
DAN CIRULI: Flexible-- you
can do anything in Flexible.
MARK MANDEL: So Flexible's fine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So it is
just like, for instance,
if you have an App
Engine app running
Go, on Standard environment,
for now, it could not work.
But you could use Flexible,
and it could work.
DAN CIRULI: That's
absolutely right.
In fact, that's why they call it
Flexible because it's, indeed--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It's more flexible.
That is actually
[INAUDIBLE] naming there.
DAN CIRULI: Among other reasons,
that's a little known fact.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great
naming right there.
MARK MANDEL: So we've talked
a lot about REST APIs here.
But as many people who
listened to the podcast know,
we're huge fans of GRPC.
Can I use this with GRPC, Sep?
SEPEHR EBRAHIMZADEH:
Yes, you can, actually.
Our GRPC support is
coming very shortly.
It is currently in
the alpha stages.
And our customers can
sign up to use that.
And there are advantages
to using GRPC,
and there are advantages
to using JSON REST.
So you'll have to see
which one is the right fit
for your application.
DAN CIRULI: I was actually
really pleasantly surprised
at how quickly we
got that question
from our alpha participants and
how readily they adopted it.
It's sometimes a little
bit hard to gauge
the success of an open source
project, GRPC in particular.
We don't know how many
people are using GRPC.
It's more than I had thought.
And, yeah, we want
that same feature
set, because whether your
API's talking REST or not,
you still want logging
and monitoring.
You still need authentication.
You still need API keys.
So you want that same
dashboard regardless of what
that protocol is, right?
MARK MANDEL: That's really cool.
Now, I'm actually quite curious.
Since GRPC is kind of HTP2
binary spec, like Protos coming
in and out, do you
get any introspection
into like the data going in
and out or anything like that?
Do you get any cool
tools that way?
DAN CIRULI: You don't right now.
In fact, in either, whether
you're using REST JSON or GRPC,
we're not introspecting
your payload.
So we're not looking at
that payload in either case.
But we can tell you what
percentage of your calls
are errors per method, what your
latencies are like at median,
again, per method, which
client is making the call.
And maybe you realize,
hey, our errors went up,
but it's all in a
particular method,
and it's all from
only the iOS client.
So it lets you tell
very quickly, OK, this
is probably a client problem
with the new release we did.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
how do you manage
exposing a Swagger
or an Open API spec
when what you are using is GRPC?
How does that work?
GRPC has a design language.
DAN CIRULI: Do you
want to take that, Sep?
SEPEHR EBRAHIMZADEH: Sure.
So our GRPC customers
inside and outside of Google
are currently using Proto to
define their API specification.
We're currently
working on integration
with Open API for GRPC services,
using cyber extensions,
for example, and other options.
But internally, what we do is we
convert the API specifications
to the same common format.
And the APIs we use
for that conversion
and exposing the
API specification
have also been published.
So if you're curious, you
can take a look at them,
and these would be under our
Service Management API set.
DAN CIRULI: Yeah,
and we can also
make a-- we'll put in
the Resources section
a link to the GitHub project.
So we have this thing called
the Google API Compiler that
can take an Open API
specification or a Proto
and a Yaml, that
together describe
how to manage a GRPC API.
They compile them this thing
we call a normalized service
config, and that's actually
the format that all
our downstream tools take.
So one thing we would like to
see, as members of the Open API
Initiative we are
working with, could there
be a single canonical
representation of an API,
regardless of whether
it's HTP JSON and HTP 1.1
or Proto and HTP 2.
So as we work with that
committee, the Open API
technical committee, we'd
like to see if there could
be a single representation.
But for now, it's either an Open
API spec or a Proto and a Yaml.
MARK MANDEL: That's really cool.
Now I'm just
thinking about how we
were talking about the GRPC
gateway that'll switch a GRPC
call into an HTP call.
So then you can put
Endpoints on top of both,
and that's pretty powerful.
DAN CIRULI: Right, and then
certainly, we're doing that
internally at Google.
A lot of our APIs now are
serving both the GRPC circuits
as well as a JSON surface.
And we'll have that, for sure.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, we had
Brandon [? Philips ?] last week
talking about how to
use GRPC [INAUDIBLE],
and they also
mentioned that they
were using the GRPC gateway,
which was very nice to hear.
DAN CIRULI: Obviously
I know that,
because I listen every week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: As you should.
[LAUGHTER]
SEPEHR EBRAHIMZADEH: Yeah, the
nice thing, as you mentioned,
is that you write your
back end, and it typically
handles either GRPC or REST.
But once you use Endpoints and
have that extensible server
proxy in front of
your back end, you
can transport back and forth.
And so your clients are
free to use whichever
suits their needs better.
DAN CIRULI: And we do want
to work with the standards
committee on making sure that
it's a canonical transformation
that you are
describing completely
with either one of those
documents what your API
surface is.
FRANCESC: Cool.
I had a question regarding one
of my least favorite topics,
which is OAuth 2.
What other kind of
authentications do you have?
You talked about one
of my favorite ones,
which is API keys, because
they're super easy to use.
Do you have any other options?
SEPEHR EBRAHIMZADEH: Yeah, so we
do support Gitkit, or Firebase
Auth, as it's called now.
We support other third-party
authentication providers,
like Auth 0.
Am I missing any others, Dan?
DAN CIRULI: No, I think
those are the important ones.
And both those, Firebase
Auth and Auth 0,
are used by mobile
developers, especially
who want their users
to log in, say,
with Facebook or with username
and password or your Twitter
login or your GitHub login.
It doesn't matter.
They have integrations
with those.
So your end user, maybe they
just log in with Facebook,
both those solutions will
generate a token, a JSON web
token that is passed across.
Endpoint can validate it
and say, yes, this really
was generated by your client.
It's an auth token.
It's valid, and here's
your user ID out of it.
MARK MANDEL: So you've
got options there.
So if you've got something
like mobile clients
and you want that particular
user to be logging in,
and then also if you're doing
maybe like service to service,
you've got those options, too.
DAN CIRULI: Right.
And that's one of the
interesting things
we saw that many
of our customers
are actually doing
two types of auth.
They've got an
external-facing service
that is validating a
user-generated auth token,
say the user logged
in with Facebook.
But then that's, in turn,
calling micro services.
And so they're using Endpoints
on those micro services
as well, and those are
taking service to service.
So they're validating
an auth token
that was created in one
of their other services.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
At least from the point
of view of the client
calling the server, having
things like Firebase Auth
is so much better,
just because you
don't need to handle the
OAuth 2 dance by yourself,
and that's a huge thing.
I don't know a
single developer that
is happy to write that
part of the code, ever.
DAN CIRULI: Right.
No one wants to do that.
That's right.
MARK MANDEL: So both
of you have actually
mentioned this thing called
an extensible server proxy,
or something along
those sort of lines.
Does one of you want to
tell us what that is,
and why is it extensible,
and why is it a proxy?
Like, what does it do?
SEPEHR EBRAHIMZADEH: (LAUGHING)
Sure, I can tackle that.
So as I mentioned, we
want the developers
to be free to choose any
language, any framework
that they want, and build
and host their APIs anywhere.
So what we're providing is
this extensible server proxy,
which is an Nginx-based
web server that sits
in front of their applications.
It's extensible
because currently it
provides features
like authentication,
monitoring, and logging.
In the future, we will
be adding other features
that our API management
customers are looking for.
And it's also extensible in
the sense that, as you know,
Nginx is an open
source project, and we
are working towards
open sourcing the proxy
as well in order to
have the open source
community be able to take it
and add other features that they
want.
DAN CIRULI: One interesting
thing about the way Endpoints
is architected-- it's different
than virtually everybody,
certainly every other cloud
provider's solution-- is
that our proxy is designed
to be containerized.
It's not what we'd think of
as a fat-shared proxy, where
every customer's API calls
are going through the same one
and then being routed
to your back end.
Rather this is a thin
container that gets deployed
alongside with your back end.
Internally at Google, we made
a switch from a shared proxy
to what we call a distributed
or server local proxy about two
years ago.
We did it for
performance reasons.
It reduces by an
order of magnitude
the amount of latency
introduced at the proxy.
It reduces a network hop.
And it's much more scalable.
So for all those reasons--
SEPEHR EBRAHIMZADEH: Yeah,
the other nice thing about it
is the decoupling.
If you have multiple APIs or
multiple micro services talking
to each other, you
can update the proxy
sitting in front of one of them
without affecting the others.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
a very good point.
So just make sure
I'm understanding
this, that means that rather
than having that exposing cloud
endpoint IP, where people go
always there and then be handed
there maybe a load
balancer and then
be handed a bunch of
machines, what you're saying
is that you could
still have basically
the same architecture,
where you're exposing
an IP from your load balancer.
And then when it gets
to every single machine,
those machines are
running a proxy.
DAN CIRULI: That's right.
Think of it as just
another container
running on those machines.
And if you're using, say,
GKE or App Engine Flex,
we make it trivial.
With App Engine Flex, that
container just pops up.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, it's just there.
DAN CIRULI: We see that there's
an API as part of your app,
and so we spin it up.
We wire traffic through it.
And so you really don't
have to do anything.
If you're using GKE, you just
say, throw this container here.
And as your app
scales and, say, you
go from serving 10 requests a
serving 1,000 requests a second
and you scale up that back
end, each one that comes up,
a server local proxy
comes up with it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
SEPEHR EBRAHIMZADEH: Right.
I just want to clarify,
though, that even though we're
big fans of containers and
use them widely within Google
and we're big fans of
the Docker Project,
you don't actually
have to use containers.
They make your
life a lot easier.
But if you want to
just deploy your code
on a raw GCEVM or a virtual
machine somewhere else,
you can definitely do that, too.
DAN CIRULI: I like that--
they make your life easier.
I mean, if you like
pain, sure, we got pain.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: So Sep,
you said something kind
of really interesting,
but you kind of
glanced past it, which is you
said the proxy's open source?
SEPEHR EBRAHIMZADEH:
Nginx Project,
which the proxy is based
on, is open source.
So we're working on
open sourcing this.
But there are a lot of
challenges open sourcing
a very large project.
DAN CIRULI: And I would say
that the challenges were there
some teams we're aligning
with internally at Google.
This is a very interesting
area-- as well as outside.
One of the reasons that projects
like GRPC and Kubernetes
have done very well is that
we actually got partners
in there and working
with the code
before it went to open
source, and it makes
sure you're in a certain state.
And so we're kind of in
that process right now.
There's a lot of people very
interested in this project,
and we want to make
sure that we don't
have to make too big
of changes after going
[INAUDIBLE] with it.
So we hope to do something soon.
MARK MANDEL: All right, sweet.
SEPEHR EBRAHIMZADEH: Right.
And as Dan mentioned, our
tooling and the implementation
of the APIs that I mentioned
are basically open source
right now.
It's very important to us to not
lock our customers in, to say,
you have to use Google Cloud
or you have to use Endpoints.
We would like these
components to be
able to stand alone
and for the APIs that
expose the infrastructure,
which is really
doing the heavy lifting.
It's the same infrastructure
that's running Google's APIs.
You could leverage
it to host your APIs
and take advantage of the
same API management features.
So that's what we are
really putting out there,
and we would like people to be
able to look at the proxy code,
look at the tooling code that
converts and analyzes the Open
API specification and also to
be able to extend it, maybe
contribute features.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So does this mean
that since we can run
Endpoints basically anywhere,
I could run the back end for
Google Cloud Endpoints outside
of the Google Cloud?
DAN CIRULI: Yes.
SEPEHR EBRAHIMZADEH:
That is correct.
We are not providing
documentation and support
for doing so yet, but
it is work in progress.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
I think that can be very
interesting, especially
for people considering
multi-cloud, the fact that you
can, with Stackdriver, you can
have monitoring multi-cloud.
And now with Cloud
Endpoints, you can actually
have also that in multi-cloud.
That is very cool.
MARK MANDEL: Very cool indeed.
So we're slowly running out
of time, not too bad yet.
I'll ask the standard
question that we always
ask-- is there anything we
haven't talked about yet
that you want to mention
or plug or talk about?
Dan, why don't you go first.
DAN CIRULI: Well,
there is one thing.
And I think, because
your listeners are really
going to wonder why
we didn't mention it--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I actually
heard the name once.
[LAUGHTER]
DAN CIRULI: Yeah,
I did say it once.
We mentioned it.
We did go on a little
shopping spree last week
and bought a company
called Apogee.
They are one of the leaders
in the API management space.
And of course, the reason we
haven't spent much time on it
is we told you going in because
the deal has been announced
but not yet closed.
Regulators on this
continent and others
prevent us from talking
about the roadmap.
So those of you who are
listening and hoping
to get the inside scoop here,
I can't say anything other
than this should make
it clear that APIs
are a big deal at Google.
And we are really excited
about our product line.
We're excited about
the acquisition
and excited about
the possibilities.
MARK MANDEL: So basically
what I'm hearing
is you're going
to come back again
once everything is closed.
DAN CIRULI: 45 days from now.
Put it on the calendar.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we can
have a longer discussion.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
That's a deal.
MARK MANDEL: Sep,
anything from you?
SEPEHR EBRAHIMZADEH:
I would just
like to send a message to
myself a few years ago when
I was building a couple mobile
apps that had a few thousand
users.
And I suddenly
overnight had to start
Googling for monitoring
services and logging services
and how do I do authentication.
And say that if you are
building a mobile app,
if you are hosting APIs,
definitely give Google Cloud
Endpoints a try.
I think you'll be pleasantly
surprised about how easy
it is to set it up, and
that you set it up once,
and you get all the
logging, monitoring,
authentication features,
with more features
to be added in the future.
So, yeah, give it a try.
DAN CIRULI: And you get
the benefit of the open API
toolchain as well, right?
So that's documentation
generation.
It's explorers to play with
your API in a web browser.
It's client library generation.
So there's a whole host of stuff
that the open source community
is producing that we're
helping to produce now
that you get as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah all the
cool things that you've ever
heard about Swagger are there.
That is very nice indeed.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, thank you to both
of you for coming on.
Really appreciate
you taking the time.
It's been a really
interesting conversation.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.,
and see you again
in 45 days, apparently?
SEPEHR EBRAHIMZADEH: Of course.
DAN CIRULI: We'll see you then.
MARK MANDEL: We'll
book in you right now.
That was a delightful
conversation
with both Dan and Sep.
I really enjoyed
learning about Endpoints.
I actually hadn't had a chance
to look at them too much yet.
So it's really nice to come
here and do the podcast
and hear about stuff that's
new, interesting on GCP
that I may not know about.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
we get to learn a lot.
I had been involved with
a Google Cloud Endpoints
project a little bit
from the beginning.
But still, I
actually did not know
that running in multi-cloud was
an option and stuff like that.
I think it's very interesting.
DAN CIRULI: Yeah, I super
hope they end up open sourcing
some of that stuff.
I think that would be
really, really awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I'm sure they will.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So why don't we get stuck into
our Questions of the Week.
We have a couple of them.
I'm probably going to
butcher people's names,
but I will try my very best.
We had two questions.
The first one's from
[? Rashandovorani? ?]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I would
say so-- [? Roshandarani. ?]
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, OK, cool.
Hi, Rashan.
He has a question about project
level custom data, or metadata,
being able to access
it from App Engine.
he doesn't seem to
be able to do it.
And he was like, hey,
Franscesc, can you
help me, because this
doesn't seem to work for me?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah, we
answered a question regarding
where to store information
like variables, environment
variables and stuff like
that, a couple episodes ago.
And we mentioned that
one of the places
was the metadata service that
has the benefit that you can
actually access it from
both Compute Engine
but also a Container
Engine and even App Engine.
And so to use it
from a App Engine,
though, the important thing
is that rather than targeting
the metadata.Google.internal
URL, that is indeed internal
and it is not accessible
from App Engine
unfortunately,
what you need to do
is you need to use
the Compute API.
So the Compute
API is a REST API,
and you can use it
from anywhere, as long
as you have the authentication.
And the default
authentication for App Engine
provides that, as long as you
ask for the compute scope.
And basically what
you're going to ask
is you going to ask for the
information about the project.
It is not a metadata thing.
It is actually inside
of the project resource.
You're going to have
a bunch of things.
And of them is all
the metadata variables
attached to that project,
not only to the instance.
So it is something that
you can definitely do.
It may be a little bit
confusing at the beginning
if you don't know
where to look at it.
So I think it was a question
that was worth answering here.
MARK MANDEL: So
basically, rather than
trying to access it
like you're running
on Compute Engine,
access it like you're
an external service coming in.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, basically,
like if it was a
mobile app or something
like that, that's how you could
access it exactly the same way.
The good thing is you
don't need to really care
about authentication because
the default authentication
from App Engine, it is
good enough to access that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
That makes sense.
Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And then, yeah, we
had another question from
Leonard Benoit or Bennett.
I don't know.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good.
I like it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Everybody
that sends emails has--
MARK MANDEL: An
interesting name.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Names
that are hard to pronounce,
which is awesome.
Mine is not easy
either, so, yeah.
So Leonard asks, OK, so we
love Google Cloud Platform.
That is good. [INAUDIBLE].
And they have an
application, which
they're running the back end
on Google Cloud Platform.
But then they have
front ends which
are an Android app, an iOS
app, and then our browser web
interface.
And the problem is
like, OK, we don't
want to write the code
for those applications
over and over for
every single time
we have a little change have
to update all our clients.
So how can we make this better
to reuse more code, basically?
And I think that you
may know about this.
MARK MANDEL: So we might have
talked about it a little bit
today, which I think
is really cool.
So, yeah, if you want to
look at Cloud Endpoints,
I think that's a really
good way to go, particularly
because it conforms to the
Swagger or the API spec.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
the Open API spec, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: And what's
cool about that is then
you can generate clients
for it, and that's
where I think you're going
to get a lot of benefit
from things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that is actually basically
what Google Cloud Endpoints used
to do for App Engine for Java
and Python.
That was exactly
what it did, right?
Like, it could generate
some specification,
which was not Open API spec.
It was a different one.
But from there, you
can autogenerate
JavaScript code, Objective
C code, and Java code.
With Swagger or
Open API Spec, you
can do the same thing, but with
many other languages, which
is pretty amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I'd be interested-- depending
on what it is you're doing,
you could also go
down the GRPC route.
But you may have some troubles
there on the web front.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
and depending on what
you're doing-- actually, no.
I was going to say
you could use Go
because Go can run both on
Android and iOs, but not web.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, so
yeah, probably not a good idea.
MARK MANDEL: There is a Go
to JavaScript transcompiler.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I know--
[? Go for ?] [? TS, ?] and it
is pretty amazing.
But still, I think there
may be a little bit
oo many moving parts.
MARK MANDEL: (LAUGHING)
You're trying to go too far?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, a little
bit too many moving pieces.
But, yeah, basically,
once you have one open API
spec or a GRPC spec,
as you're saying,
basically you're going
to get the possibility
of autogenerating the client
libraries you get called will
be specific for each platform.
And that will make
your life much easier.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
and definitely
listen to the beginning
part of this podcast
if you haven't already.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh,
yeah, absolutely.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Well, thank you
very much, Francesc,
for joining me once again.
Are you up to any
interesting things lately?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Not
really. (LAUGHING)
No, I'm still planning
my trip to Brazil.
That is my next big trip.
I'm also going to be-- at
the beginning of October
I will be in New York.
And I'm organizing a
couple of Go events,
and I might be able to run
a Google Cloud Platform
specific event.
But we're still
planning on that.
MARK MANDEL: Ooh, nice.
I'm going to be
wandering around.
Google's having an
Google Play Indie
Festival, so for indie game
developers, on this Saturday
after this podcast
will come out.
So I'll be wandering about
that just chatting to people
and saying hello.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That sounds fun.
Where is that?
MARK MANDEL: That's
here in San Francisco.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I think
there's a wait list now.
So if you're already
registered, yay.
And if you're not, you might
want to get on the wait list.
And then in a couple of weeks--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We'll have
a llink in the show notes
to that.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
And a couple weeks
after that I'll
be at another gaming
conference called Siege,
where I'll be presenting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
Sounds like a fun week.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Well,
yeah, thank you again,
and talk to you all next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you then.